Hi Charles, welcome to the next lesson.
>> Hi Michael thank you for
welcoming me to the next lesson.
What is the next lesson?
>> So I don't know, can you read it?
>> I can read some of it I
can't quite see all of it.
[LAUGH] I get it.
>> So the other topic is
partially observable MDPs but
I made MDPs partially observable.
>> Brilliant.
>> Kind of fell off
the bottom of the screen.
So yeah so this is the idea of talking
about Markov decision processes
like we've been talking about, but
ones where the agent has to make
decisions based on what it can see
of the Markov decision process,
not necessarily the true and
current state.
>> You know we talked a little
bit about this in the old
machine learning class, didn't we?
But just a little.
>> Okay, all right, well so
then we're going to get a little bit
more into it, maybe, I don't know.
What did we talk about last time?
>> I don't know.
I don't remember,
just that there was-- we mentioned I
think we mentioned that they exist.
>> Okay.
So
we're going to talk about how they work.